hey guys tie here with Eric today with
another division video at the crafting
station where Eric is going to show me
his badass Tenebrae blueprint the gun
that you made and then we're gonna go
messin guys up yeah so the Tenebrae is a
new named blueprint that was sold at the
dark zone special gear vendor this week
that that cycles once a week so last
week the normal special gears vendor was
selling the Liberator which I made last
week which is probably pretty cool gun
and we made a video on that so that's
why we're going to show you this new
marksman rifle I made this it's pretty
cool it also has four talents that you
can roll it rolls one random talent with
the other three being steady brutal and
toxic brutal is an amazing talent
because it just increases headshot
damage and hedgehog damage is already
really high on marksman rifles yeah
that's a really nice one and toxic is
pretty fun to use because if you get
them in the head you know you can
potentially blind them and so it's like
having like a mini flash grenade as long
as you get headshots that's alright and
in proc psych thirteen percent of the
time at least ha on the blueprint and
most of these these gold weapons don't
always have for talent is it attributed
to them so that the Fatiha for here is
pretty impressive yeah like you said
this one for some reason just has a
fourth random talent my Liberator when I
made it only had three so that's what
makes this one pretty cool and you know
if you want to keep rolling them I got
Providence which is the last bullet
feeling more fifty-six percent more
damage which is not bad but this clip is
so huge it's like a 37 clip it's
sometimes I catch myself reloading
Midway and I don't think about using the
last bullet but that would make sense as
to why you know sometimes I see this
huge crit on that last bullet but yeah
it's pretty fun gun let's a take it out
and you know mess some fools up with it
shall we I want to see it
you
you
Wow systems clean